- Yo, yo, yo this is Ruben
Harris, I'm here with the homies
Artur and Timur Meyster, and this is the
Breaking into Startups podcast.
Timur, can you please tell the people
what we're doin' today?
- Yes, so today we're
actually sitting here,
in San Mateo, and we're
recording this episode
out of Hero City Draper University,
and this doesn't always happen
but we have a lot of
cameras rolling right now,
we actually have a live audience,
and that's because we have
a very cool guest today,
and Ruben, can you please
introduce the guest?
- Yes sir, we're here
with Gary Vaynerchuk,
who many of you know as
a rock star entrepreneur,
but he's also a author and a speaker,
he's a four time New
York Times bestseller,
he runs a 800 person media agency,
he was a early investor in
Twitter, Snapchat and Uber.
And what's amazing about
this podcast episode
is we're not just gonna
talk about how to build
companies, we're gonna talk about how
a lot of people launch a company
without understanding how this game works.
And, what it takes to break into a job,
learn different skills
and kinda go from there,
but before doin' that, just
wanna say welcome Gary.
- Thanks guys, I'm really excited
about this, appreciate it.
- Yeah, so a lot of folks out there,
who are listening, they're
obsessed with companies,
right, starting companies,
but a lot of them,
may not have the skills, so if you're,
I guess 25, 35, 45 and
you are starting over,
and you wanna eventually own a company,
what would you do now
to acquire that skill,
to become that entrepreneur
that you wanna be like?
- So I think, you know,
just getting the sense
of the energy of the
podcast and the audience,
I think the first thing that we have
to really do here is take a step back.
We need to understand
when there are bubbles.
And when there are trends
that are gonna hurt people.
And this notion, for
people that are under 25,
that starting a company has kind of become
the goin' to grad school,
has become going to college,
has become, I've gotta
save for retirement,
I have to buy a home,
I have to get married,
like it has become, like, standard,
and I think that's insane, and scary,
because that is literally
like going to the NBA
has become standard.
It is very hard to build
a very big business.
Like, most people will
never build a business
that makes a million, like 99% of people
don't have the ability
or will ever achieve,
running a business that makes
a million dollars profit,
let alone the audacity, and the,
and it's awesome, I mean
blind youth, listen,
I went on, not knowing much,
like you guys just said,
sorry, it's a directional,
not a, and I'm like,
I don't know anything, but
the one thing I've always
known is how to make money
and build a business.
And it's crazy, you know,
a rock star entrepreneur.
Those two words were never
together just seven years ago?
Like, this has become a
real thing that is a bubble.
It's a bubble, now, does
that mean the person
on the other side of this
can't build a business?
Absolutely not.
But I think you need to
start with self awareness.
There's a lotta good kids,
a lot of people out there
that are really good
workers, are really smart,
super organized, like
have unbelievable amounts
of skills, and my biggest
fear, and I say this a lot,
is, oh, shit, this is gonna be the era
where a lot of people could've went,
and been number 13, at
Reddit, number 41 at Facebook,
number 109 at Google and Yahoo!, instead,
they think they need to be
number one at laundry land,
and they're gonna waste a lot of money,
a lot of time, now the
reason a lot of people
have done this is there's
been a lot of easy money.
Been so much money in venture capital.
Now, that easy money
has been really directed
mainly towards white
males from good schools.
So it not like, you know,
when people are listening,
they're like what is he talkin' about,
like, I understand what I'm talking about,
but I also understand
how not everybody's been
able to get to it.
By the way, I would've never
been able to get to it,
because even though I'm a white male,
I was a shit student,
and as a matter of fact,
remember we were talkin'
before and you said
hey, so remind me about the
fund, and I was like no,
I've have a 25 million dollar fund,
I was about to raise
150 million dollar fund,
but I put it on the side,
but when I was going through
that, two years ago, on
the back of investing
in Facebook, and Twitter,
and Tumblr, and Uber,
and all these things, before they popped,
on the back of that, there
were still family offices,
that didn't wanna write me checks,
because I went to Mount
Ida college, not Stanford.
And I was like, and I loved it,
like I love losing, like I like
getting punched in the mouth.
I just thought it was ludicrous.
I'm like wow.
You literally think a piece of paper
matters more than fuckin' results.
I'm not talkin' shit, I did shit.
- Yeah.
Exactly, man.
- So, anyway, nonetheless, man, there's
a lot to cover here, but the biggest thing
and the reason I'm
starting with this rant,
is please, don't think you have to.
Please.
Here's a good one.
If you're 22 years old,
and you never sold shit,
growing up, you've got a problem.
Convincing me, that you're gonna
build some big time business.
- Yep.
- Like, if you didn't sell blow pops,
if you didn't download music,
like on CD's and flip them,
if you didn't do what
I did which was, man,
I was lemonade stand at five, you know,
raking leaves, washing cars, I'm Jewish
and sang fucking Christmas
carols for a dollar.
So, like, you know, so
like, baseball cards,
that was my whole life.
And I just think a lotta
people who are academia
oriented, by the way, who I value.
Like the people that I plan
on making multi millionaires,
are people that have those
skills, 'cause I don't,
and you need a team, not
everybody's the quarterback,
somebody's the left
tackle, you need a punter,
you need 'em all, this whole everybody's
gotta be a startup founder,
'cause they think they can,
here's the problem, in business
it's different than singing.
On American Idol, back in the day,
when you went in front of Simon,
when we all watched
those first two episodes
where they showed all the bad people,
nobody was confused
that you sucked, right?
But with business, it takes some time
to figure out if you suck.
Like, it feels like anybody could start,
and then when everybody got checks,
like free money,
everybody built businesses
that they were losing money every month.
- Exactly.
- This town that we're
sitting in right now,
the last seven years, what I've watched,
it doesn't take a hero to
raise two million dollars
and then lose 30 thousand dollars a month,
until you run out, and then start over
and be like, I learned something.
So it's a broken game, but,
it's an incredible game,
I'm not tryin' to stop
anybody from doing it,
here's what I would say.
Don't amass debt to start a business,
if you don't know you're good.
Fine, if you wanna raise
capital from other people,
but remember when you lose they remember.
And when you're 27 and you've got
a scarlet letter on your
chest, and nobody good ever
wants to fuck with you, that's bad.
It's definitely bad if you
lost your aunt's money,
'cause that's just
weird, you know, and so,
if they wanna be successful here's my,
here's my two cents on this, I think kids
should go work for people for free,
and keep it humble, for
the first three years.
Free to as little as possible.
I think every one of you, in this room,
should like live in the
same one bedroom apartment.
But work for the best person
you can get in front of,
for free, 'cause the IP, the intelligence,
watching how people do it, I promise you.
Maribel, who's sitting across from me,
who's on my team, and the office CO,
and the special project, you know,
she's got her masters, she's got all this,
listen, she may not
agree, 'cause she doesn't
always agree with me,
which, I love her for that,
but like I know she learned
a lot this last year,
and it's different than what
you learn in a classroom.
You just can't, you can't
learn it, it's like sports.
Like you could read
books about how to play
basketball, but until you
get on the court, the fuck?
And that's what's happening, and so,
yeah, I'm not tryin' to be Debbie Downer,
I just want practicality
back in the system,
because I think a lotta
people, you have to understand,
people wrap their self
esteem up in their business.
You start a new business, you're 24,
you're telling your mom, your homies,
you're like I got this
business, and you're
fucking flashin' it,
and you put entrepreneur
in the title of your Instagram,
and you're on blast now,
and when it fails, all your
self esteem goes with it,
and I wanna remind everybody,
99% are gonna fail.
- Yep.
- This isn't 50.
So like everybody who's
sayin' like yeah, yeah,
but I'm gonna break through, cool.
But like 99% are gonna fail.
Plus the economy's been phenomenal
for nine years in a row now.
- Yep
- So all the kids, you've
gotta be 32 to even
basically kinda remember
when shit was bad,
so if you're under 32, you've never been
punched in the fuckin'
mouth, so you don't even know
the difference, you think
it's just always gonna be
like this, you don't know
what it really looks like.
You're not winning and building a business
during easy times, what
the fuck do you think
is gonna happen when no money is around?
- Yeah.
- So, I'm concerned, but I'm optimistic.
I just wish people got
real with themselves.
- Yeah.
And you say a lot about
like workin' nine to fives,
and like workin' for free is one thing,
but you also talked about how, like,
making time is an interesting thing,
so during the job, while
you're saving money,
you can do a lot of things
with those extra hours
to continue to develop
skills, can you kinda
continue to elaborate about that?
- Yeah, look I think we're
talking about our lives.
So when you're talkin' about your life,
my big thing is like,
you better go, a lotta
people are like Gary V.,
just peddles like all hustle,
and it's not healthy, I'm
like look, I talk about
sleeping six, seven hours a day.
I want everybody to sleep.
I'm just curious about the other sixteen.
- Yep.
- I'm curious about your sixteen hours.
I don't know, I'm programmed every minute.
Like I'm, 'cause I'm
ambitious, 'cause I want it.
And so, you know, I'm
struggling, there's a lot
of 24 year olds who've
watched the entire season
of Crown, and I'm just like, yo, if you're
gonna be a billionaire,
like, that's a bad idea.
- Totally.
- you know, and they're
dominant at Candy Crush,
and they're like, they're
real Call of Duty gangsters,
and they listen to like every new album,
the second it comes out, like they're just
spending a lot of time, and listen,
you should have leisure,
you should have escapism.
You do you everybody's got different DNA.
My big thing is like, people
complain, and people talk shit.
And if you do either one of those two,
I need to see you workin'.
- Yeah.
- And so you could be workin' nine to six,
paying off your college
debt, I'm just curious
to know what's happening 7:30 to midnight.
And when I start looking
at those four and a half
to five hours, when I really dig in deep
and get to know a kid, or if
I have a real conversation,
when I start hearing two of
those four and half hours
are being wasted, times five days a week,
seven days a week, in a
world where I know what I did
and I also know what the
people that I've seen
be successful did, which
is, it's obsession.
It's every minute.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
That's 168 hours in a week, like you said.
- Yeah.
And I think, also, growing
up with immigrant parents.
Timur and I immigrated
from Ukraine when we were
eleven, and seeing how
hard our parents worked,
they moved to a new
country without knowing
a word of English, my dad
was working in a factory
and my mom was, like,
doing like, she was like
working in like various like maid roles.
And just seeing how
- Right, fuckin' cleanin' people's shit.
- Yeah.
And they working like 10, 12 hours a day
and then coming home, tryin' to like
maintain a family, and I
think just seeing that,
and I know you talk a
lot about your family,
how hard you worked, just I think,
the whole mindset, like
the immigrant mindset,
I wish more people have adopted it.
And just, kind of
understood what it takes,
how hard other people work.
- My man, when you talk
about entrepreneurship,
immigrants have a ridiculous advantage.
Because they know the alternative.
If you're born in America,
the richest fuckin'
country in the world, even if you're not
that good, you're still soft.
Compared to the rest of the world.
- Yep.
- I have a lot of friends
who grew up super humbly,
like I went to Mount Ida College, 90%
of the college was
African-American, Latino,
and like, and like,
some ghetto kids, right.
Anyway, I just remember like,
since the last 20 years,
like just remember like, how many times
someone told me things
like, man, I thought
I grew up tough in
Newark, but like I visited
my family in like, Haiti.
Or like, you know, or
like, I just think we lose
perspective, and I think
you're right, like, I didn't
see my dad until I was 14
years old, even though he slept
in the same home as me
every night of my life.
- Wow.
- Because he left before I
got up and he came home after,
and my mom didn't have a
maid, my mom was the maid,
with three kids, like, my
mom never had any help,
we didn't have a babysitter, I was never
watched by a babysitter in my entire life.
Like, we worked.
Like, worked.
Like, real work.
And, yeah, I think people, I think people
are unbelievably soft, to the ambition
coming out of their mouth.
You have to understand, if you tell me,
I don't wanna work.
I wanna be on a softball team,
I wanna enjoy my weekends.
I wanna watch The Crown.
I wanna be good at fuckin' Angry Birds.
I wanna see my kids.
I'm like, that's fuckin' great.
Mazel tov, like, amazing.
And if you wanna make
between 50 and 250 thousand
dollars a year, I think a lot of people
can achieve that, depending on their job.
Ya start creeping into
like three, four, five,
six hundred land, you're
gonna be an executive
somewhere, and they're
gonna expect you to work
for three, four, five, six
hundred thousand dollars a year.
- 100%.
- You start talkin' shit outta your mouth
that you're gonna make a million,
what the fuck do you
think that looks like?
- Yeah.
- Like, there's no passive income.
- Yep.
- you gotta work for it.
- Gary, you talk a lot
about, kinda the people
that you surround with,
they're the, kinda like,
the reflection of where you're gonna go,
and I was watching one of
your videos where you said,
for 2018 gain a fan, lose a fan.
Can you share with our
listeners why it's important
to be careful who you
surround yourself with?
- Yeah.
So this is a tough subject matter, right,
because as soon as this
content always comes up,
people get made at me,
they're like yo, why do you
want me to drop my boy,
like, I get it, right?
Here's what I'm saying.
I've been on a huge kick
about self awareness,
huge kick on mental
strategies, you know, tryin'
to find the fine line
between, like, what people
think I am, like a
motivational speaker, you know,
I'm scared, because I don't
wanna be a motivational speaker.
But I know like, if you only watch me
on Instagram or YouTube,
you could get tricked.
So I'm always like trying to find angles,
and I've really been getting
into strategy, more and more.
I'm like, oh, my mindset is my strategy.
It's not like I believe in
The Secret, like if you're
optimistic or positivity,
like you, you can do it!
I don't think you, you,
you, you can do it!
Is important, 'cause it's a match.
- Yep.
- Like, rah-rah's important
'cause it's a match.
But I also know, a week later,
people go back to their normal place.
So I'm tryin' to think
about, marathon mindset.
I think one of the biggest
things is who the fuck
you hang out with, here's why.
D-Rock, let's use him.
I just think he's a
different fuckin' dude,
hangin' out with me,
for the last few years.
(laughing)
And to be very honest with
you, it's not even close.
Like watching certain
insecurities, certain,
it's been game changing.
Like, I watch people
that are closest to me,
when they come to me,
build a lot of confidence,
because I have a lot of confidence,
I'm rubbing off on them.
I also watch how I change,
whether it's my wife,
or Maribelle, or Marcus, or
Claude, or whoever it may be.
Or my team, or D-Rock,
like I think about creative
differently than I did three years ago,
because D-Rock rubbed off
on me, that's what happens.
You look at an old, married
couple, they're the funniest.
I wish you could see it.
Like, it's amazing what
happens with couples.
They like gel into each other, right.
Like, and that's what happens.
I think a lot of people, hang out with
somebody, who's a negative vibe.
- Yeah.
- And I just think that,
some people hang out
with four negative vibes,
so, if your mom's negative,
right, and your older sister's negative,
and you have two negative best friends,
fuck it, drop one of those
two and go to the light,
and try to find the most positive person.
It's just so obvious to me.
I see it every day.
There's people that either are trying
to build you up, because they're good.
I'm popular because I'm so good inside,
that I'm tryin' to build all of you up,
because I don't think it's
comin' out of my pocket.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna get mine.
- 100%.
- And so, I want you to be happy.
And so, then that makes me happy.
But if you're sad, you're
tryin' to bring people down.
Somebody goes on my Instagram account
and trolls me, I feel sad for them.
When they tell me I'm ugly, or stupid,
or I suck, like, I have a lot of female
entrepreneurs I'm an
investor with, a lot of them
are like Gary, I wanna be like you,
but when I go out there, I have to deal
with all the woman
shit, and they're right.
Right, like, dudes are
fuckin' gross, and like,
and even if not dudes, you
just see other women like,
women bash women and I've
been studyin' a little bit,
like the last couple
months, like, you know,
why are you wearing that, I'm like geez,
that's super conservative,
like that's like
the dress is to the knee, it's not like,
ya know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- But it's all the same
game, it's not women
on women crime, it's
not dudes being gross,
it's people who are not in a good place,
trying to drag somebody else down.
- Yeah.
- And so, that's why I
think it's a big deal.
I think it's painful.
You've been homies with the person, or,
it's your mother, like
I think people should
drop their mother, like
not really, hear me out,
like, you're not gonna
drop your mother forever,
but maybe you don't
need to talk to your mom
three times a day if she's super negative,
maybe you need to talk to
her three times a week.
And that will change your life.
Like I don't understand, if, it's become
the most obvious thing to me in the world
and so I'm hopeful that
I can break through,
I'm desperate that one
person listening right now,
is like fuck it, and if it's like somebody
you can kind of get rid of, you know,
like a friend is easier.
Family scares me, and the
amount of people who have
a positive father and mother,
both, are almost nobody.
- Yeah.
- No, it's a real thing.
And I'm glad that you brought up D-Rock,
'cause he actually wrote a post on Medium,
what was the name of that post again?
Well he has a bunch of posts on Medium
that you guys can read about breaking in.
What were the specific
things that D-Rock did,
that like jumped out to
you, that other people
could take advice on, to learn how to like
make an impression with someone that's,
has a schedule like yours?
- He worked for free, he made a piece
of content for free, and it was good.
And he was perse, he persevered.
I think he emailed me three or four times,
we've established, right, D-Rock?
Like, you know, and he
did it tastefully, right,
like, in the last week
two people have emailed me
47 times in a row, thinking
like that's gonna penetrate me.
All that does, if you
email me 47 times in a row
and spam my inbox like
that, all that's happening
is I'm hitting my IT department
and you're getting blocked for life.
Like you're not winning that game.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, there's
a fine line between
perseverance and annoyance,
he's just a good person
so it came natural to
him and just, you know.
And he made something.
He did something.
People talk.
He made something, I liked
it, we did another thing,
and then very quickly I intuitively
was like, let's jump on board.
I do it all the time.
I'm one of the, I get paid so much money
to do a speech, it's
not even funny, right.
I get paid more money
now to give one singular
speech, then I made for the
year, financially, 14 years ago.
At 28 years old, I did not make
150 thousand dollars that year.
I now get paid 150 thousand dollars,
minimum, to give a speech.
How?
I spoke for free.
- Yep.
Yep.
- I put, I put it on wax,
you know what I mean?
- Exactly.
- And all these people
walkin' around and saying
well then you're not, don't work for free,
because that's what you're
worth, right, get your worth.
Like, on this high
horse, you know all that.
I'm like, cool, but when
nobody wants to hire you,
(laughing)
means you're worth zero.
What you have is you have these creators,
and artists, who've gotten paid,
who don't want the supply and demand
of an issue of the work getting diluted.
I think every business person
should give away free content.
Doesn't scare me.
- Yeah.
- It's like givin' out mix tapes.
- I'm like, I'm doin' it.
- It's all about adding
value first, once you
show them enough value,
then they'll come to you
and offer you whatever you wanna get.
- Also, don't be fancy.
Like, guess what.
Like, Slack doesn't give a fuck
that you worked at Goldman Sachs.
- Facts.
- So like, so, when
you're making a switch,
you gotta start over and be humble.
Like, I, I'm tryin' to
think of a good one.
I had something recently,
last two or three years,
where I did something new, and I just,
actually, probably the way I
negotiated my K-Swiss deal.
My K-Swiss sneaker deal, like,
I negotiated super humbly.
Like I knew what was gonna happen,
but even though I knew,
even though I had all
the leverage, I negotiated
it like I was a first timer.
VaynerMedia.
Even though I was this,
kind of emerging cool kid
in the web 2.0, tech
world, and knew Zucks,
and Travis, and you know,
Ev and was this real thing,
real, like real real, when
I went to Madison Avenue,
nobody gave a fuck.
And I didn't walk out there
and say, oh, I'm here now.
I ate shit for three, four years,
stayed real, real, real quiet.
And like, so, I think that, I think that,
it's stunning to me, this is the problem,
with having it a certain way.
Like if you were a great student,
and then you went to Penn, and then
you went to work at Wall Street,
and now you've decided you're miserable,
which would make a lotta
sense to me, right,
'cause for a lot of kids, once they've
achieved some money, they're like,
okay, that didn't fill me up, actually,
especially when they come from money.
Ya know, it's funny, this is a funny thing
to say, especially given
the context of today's day,
I feel equally weird about rich kids
getting into depression as I do non-white
kids struggling with
coming up from nothing.
We don't have empathy.
I don't expect a black
boy who's from welfare
to feel bad for thirstin'
Thompson the third,
who has a million dollars
in his trust fund,
when he's nine, it's just, but I just know
that some of the most deeply depressed,
struggling people I know, had it so easy.
- Yeah.
- Wake up at thirty, are not happy,
not fulfilled, have that weird life,
they go to make that switch,
but they don't have humility.
- Yeah.
- They're stuck.
They've been built a certain way,
they don't have the ability.
What people that deal with adversity do,
is they have a chip on their shoulder,
they usually get too over angry,
but they definitely have humility.
- Yeah.
- 'cause they were forced into humility.
I have unlimited humility, all my teachers
told me I sucked shit.
Super hard to think you're great.
(laughing)
Like, you know, so.
- Yeah.
- For a lot of the people that,
might see entrepreneurship as the MBA,
and they understand there's a lotta steps
to get in, they're a little bit older too.
You talk about the age and
like, learning a new skill,
like, what are your thoughts about
people that might be in
their like forties or fifties
that wanna switch.
- I think they have the, you know,
that's the biggest, funny thing to me.
All the 20 year olds are
jumpin' into this game
and meanwhile, all 40
year olds and 50 year olds
are more likely to win it,
because they have context.
Like, it's crazy to me
that I look at an 18,
I look at 22 year old dude, who's like,
I'm starting a start up company,
and then a 49 year old woman walks in
and says I've been an
accountant for 23 years,
I wanna build this startup.
She always interests me
more, because usually
the next thing out of her
mouth is, yeah, I've been
an accountant for 31 years,
I noticed that I couldn't
find the product that helped me do this.
She's scratching her itch from experience,
meanwhile the dude is looking
to make the Uber of pancakes.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- you know what I mean, so
like, so, I would tell you,
and I don't know your
audience and I assume
you're asking this question 'cause--
- Yeah.
- Which excites me, that
you have this audience.
There was a video I made, I don't remember
what it was called, D-Rock,
like for 40, 50, 60 year olds,
five minutes from the
next 50, six minutes,
six minutes from the next
60 years of your life.
And it was completely made
for people 40 and above.
Yeah man, look, I've
got some weird thoughts.
I have this dream recurring,
and it's not a dream,
what do you call 'em, daydreams,
like, visions during the day.
I keep thinking about this, I guess
that's a dream, I get it.
I keep havin' this
thought about this woman,
I'm not joking, by the
way, I've never said this,
I keep having this
thought, about this woman,
she's 74, she, her husband just died,
she was suppressed because
of the era she grew up in,
she was dramatically more entrepreneurial
and had more ability to build a business
than her husband, she
raised a great family
because of that, 'cause she had the EQ,
and she's gonna live another 22 years,
she just doesn't know it.
- Yep.
- And then I think about technology.
I think about a 1984 her, she's just gonna
live in a retirement
home and be super social
and super cool and she'll make some money
playin' cards and she'll be cool,
and then I think about
2017, and I think about
73 year old her, and I
think about her ability
to build a business online.
Buying stuff, you know, in China,
and flipping it on
Amazon retail arbitrage.
Starting an Instagram
page around her passion,
around making sneakers from scratch.
Like, this thought, and
what I think is gonna happen
is with modern medicine,
and just happiness
in your heart and your brain, I think
we're gonna start seeing
people, this is not a joke,
I think we're gonna
start seeing people live
to 120, 115, 'cause they're
gonna be in the game.
And when your brain shuts
down, after you retire,
a lotta times your body goes with it.
So, man, I think 38 to 65 is the obvious,
really, interesting age group, that should
really be fuckin' paying
attention to technology
and the opportunities for them, but I'm
and I don't think there
is as many 73 year olds
who've just lived life, who are like
fired up to grind it out.
But I think as these
73 year olds become 73
who've lived with the
internet for 20 years,
and at 53 were professionals and like,
I think we're about this, I
would argue the following,
and I been thinking about this a lot.
That some of the biggest startups,
or, let me rephrase,
'cause I think it does take
a youth, and a different eye,
lemme go a different way.
A very intriguing place
for me, as an investor,
is to start investing
in people's companies
who are over 70, starting
their first ever business,
because I think a lot
of them are gonna build
five million dollar
year businesses kicking
a million dollars in profit.
I don't expect them, as
much, and I could be wrong.
But I don't intuitively feel the Ubers,
and the Slacks, and you know, the Wazes
are coming out of that.
But do I think a direct
to consumer jelly company,
like peanut butter and jelly,
do I think a sock company,
do I think a handkerchief
company, do I think
a pillow company, do I think an eight
to 15 million dollar retail business,
based on content and
product, is gonna be coming,
like I've been weirdly thinking about,
ya know, a retirement
home, that's an incubator.
(laughing)
- That's really interesting.
- It's interesting, right?
- That's really a first.
- Like, literally, I
mean, this is the first
time I've ever said it, D-Rock?
- Yeah, I've never heard it.
- 'Cause I've been marinating.
I'm like, oh, I got an idea.
What if it's a retirement home, they don't
want, you know how many people don't,
they don't wanna go to retirement homes.
What if it's a retirement home that's like
a fuckin' Facebook like
campus, it's an incubator.
- They spend so time,
like, lookin' at clothes
for their kids, they
probably know all the deals
at Kohl's and Marshall's.
- Oh, don't even start on those.
My man, you got it.
What 16 year olds are doing with Supreme,
and fuckin' Yeezy's, I think 78 year old
Gertrude can fuckin'
crush it at Marshall's
and TJ Maxx, like and like, honestly.
And what's been great
about this is, I've been
really excited about this
'cause I'm like yeah,
like I'm gonna do some fuckin' do
some real Yoda shit 80 to 130.
Like, now all of a sudden
it's like, you know.
Now it's like, this is why I
always talk about being young.
When I hang out with all you
characters, you don't know.
Because I know when I
was 20, how old are you?
When I was 19, somebody
42 was like a thousand.
(laughing)
Like when I left, when I
left my, when I started
into my dad's business, my cousin was 30,
I was 22, he was old as shit to me.
I remember, I remember thinking, like oh,
that's some different
shit, like I'm a kid.
That's like a grown up.
So, he sits here and he looks at me,
and is like, yeah, okay, maybe like,
I've got a little bit more, like street
cred for a 42 year old, but it's still 42.
Yet, I feel like we're friends.
Like, I look at him and
I'm like we're the same.
And if kids knew that.
I'll give you one.
If guys knew that they should
fuckin' shut their mouth,
really work, through their twenties,
make no money the first five years, learn,
really then do something.
And all the things they
want in their twenties,
like girls, closing the
gap of their insecurities,
clothes, bling, that
the way to really do it,
is to eat shit from 20 to
31, build that foundation,
then slowly start building something.
When you're a 37 year old guy, guess what,
and the dynamics that are in the world,
you can date plenty of 25 year old women
if you chose to, it's
not even looked frowned,
it's not 60 and 20, like you can do plenty
of that stuff, but guys
don't think like that.
- No.
- It's impatient.
And so, they're just, I just think
most of the world's doing it wrong.
- Yeah.
- I really do.
- And on the podcast,
we actually talk about
this notion of looking at your perceived
disadvantages, and turning
them into advantages.
So, to your point, like a 70 year old,
might think of it as
like, it's a perceived
disadvantage, or it's a disadvantage,
but in reality, if
you're like a 70 year old
who wants to start a
business, you can appeal
to other 70 year olds who
are not starting a business.
So there is a lot less competition,
you can find something
that's unique about you.
- You have time.
- You have time, yeah.
- You have time, you often
have some form of money,
but you have the best part.
You fuckin' lived life.
- Yep.
- The reason kids create
Uber, and Facebook,
is, they know nothing, so they reinvent.
That's why they make billions.
But when you're 70, and
you've seen everything,
you can make a five, 10
million dollar business,
'cause you're like I've
seen this rodeo before.
And like I'll do this,
'cause it's gonna be for
three years, or when the fad
comes and goes, you've learned.
- Yeah, and when you're in your twenties
and thirties and like
you're thinking about
working for free and eatin'
shit for awhile or whatever,
like, what do you think,
so I've also heard you say,
don't live for the weekend, like do stuff
- Yeah, if you live for
the weekend your shit
is broken, look, if your best
moment is Friday afternoon,
that means you hate your
Monday through Friday.
And people get mad at
me, and because like,
Gary, fuckin' I look
forward to the weekends,
I love my family, it's
not all about money,
you're such an asshole, it's family.
I'm like no, no, no, you're not listening.
If you are so unhappy, don't
forget, 168 hours, right.
You're talking about 60,
you take in commuting,
you can be in the ball,
getting ready and commuting,
working a little bit
from home, email, just,
you're talking about half,
when it's all said and done,
oh, wait, I'm sorry, you take
in sleeping, more than half
your, actually, it's
actually not even close.
You basically live to work.
If you're unhappy, where are you going?
- Yeah.
- Like, so, yeah, yeah,
I think about it a ton.
If you're not happy, and
by the way, everything
I've just said for the last half an hour,
if you're happy, and agree
with nothing I've said,
well, you've won.
I don't wanna, who am I to judge?
- Totally.
- Yeah.
- I'm just tryin' to give
people some perspective, on,
there's too many people
who are making money
off of people making mistakes, and I just
don't wanna be that guy.
Like, I'm not, I don't
wanna be, somebody who,
let me give you a great
idea I have right now.
Ya wanna be a bad guy?
Wanna be a bad gal?
Start lending people
with real interest money
so they can buy crypto currency.
Here's why.
I'm a fan of crypto, but a lotta
money's gonna be lost on crypto.
- Yeah.
- Crypto, listen, I was
right about the internet.
There's been a lotta money
lost on the internet.
- Yep.
- People are treating it like a bonanza.
I know kids already who've
really put themselves
in bad spots 'cause they
took four credit cards out,
maxed 'em, and bought
bitcoin at 17 thousand.
'cause they thought it was gonna be 34.
It's already happened.
- Yeah.
- And it hasn't even,
didn't need to crash.
- Yeah.
- People treat it like a bonanza.
- Let me just say this.
And let this sink in, and
stick in your fuckin' brain,
for the rest of your life,
there is no easy money.
- Yeah.
- Like the second you fuckin' go there,
everything will change.
There's no easy money.
You might've had an easy money event,
but there's no easy money.
- Yeah.
- There's nothing consistent.
You've might've, you could win the lotto.
Life is like a casino.
You can tell me you went
last Thursday and won $2,000,
and like, this is great, keep going.
- Yeah.
Yeah, no, that's good insight.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, 100%.
And then like, thinkin' about
your point about happiness,
and how that's like, extremely important,
you also talk a lot about mental health.
- Yes.
- And like, as you're goin'
through these five years,
or 10 years, tryin' to learn the game,
and sometimes it feels
like it's goin' nowhere,
what are some routines, or what are
your thoughts around like
maintaining mental health,
or meditation, you talk about
a lotta that type of stuff.
- I think it starts with self esteem.
Ya know, I think a lot of
people are drugging themselves,
or looking at meditation,
or trying to find things
to get those voices out of their head,
if you didn't wrap your self esteem up in,
I don't, listen, crazy thing to say,
it's shocking to me how
much my self esteem is not
wrapped up into my
business accomplishments
when it's basically who I am.
Because I don't share
anything about my family,
so nobody really knows me that way,
I am shocked about that.
And it just makes me so
happy, it makes me so strong.
- Yeah.
- Right, 'cause I'm like, I just,
I just want people to be happy.
- That's yours, too, like, that's probably
how you balance a little bit too, right?
- Yeah, sure.
Here's my thing.
Honestly, it was funny, you
kinda caught my attention
a little bit different, but
like what the real thing is,
is let's go real basic, it's mine.
- Yeah.
- The reason my life is good, is some way,
between my mom parenting her
ass off, being an immigrant,
DNA, who the hell else
knows what other factors.
Somewhere very early, everything became,
this is me, this is mine,
nobody else, nobody,
I mean, you would be
flabbergasted with my inability
to take somebody's
point of view on things,
and take it to mean more than my own.
I don't think I'm always
right, I respect the shit
out of other people's
opinions, I spend a lot of time
watching them, but
nobody's judgment of me,
that I'm a failure, ever, ever penetrates,
ever, ever, ever.
- Yeah.
- And I want that for others,
and I'm tryin' to think
about ways to talk about it.
To me, you know, everything's mine.
It's mine.
It's like great, I lost.
You're, you saying I lost, means nothing
compared to me thinking I lost.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean, like.
And so, I don't know, I
think people are using
too much outside validation
to navigate their lives.
I use no outside navigation.
Even though I'm so public,
and I'm so out there.
It's why I never, you know,
the reason I grow audience
is because I never care about
how many followers I have.
It's never run through my mind once.
- Yeah.
- And for the people that don't know,
like what are some things
that you got goin' on
for the rest of the year,
I know you got a new book
comin' out, might be out already.
- No, no, it comes out in
five days, which is exciting.
I'm sure by the time
you air this it's out.
So that's exciting.
- Crushing it, right?
- Crushing it.
It's the followup to the
book that really put me on,
it's really fun to read
Crush It now, I wrote it
nine years ago, it came
out eight years ago, or 10,
it came out 2008, yeah, I wrote it
10 years ago, it came out nine years ago.
I was so fuckin' right.
Like, honestly though, like,
you have to understand,
like people didn't think
you could make money
on YouTube, or blogging, like,
it ended up being so true.
And I'm trying to that again with this.
Which is not about
predicting, it's just like,
people don't realize,
like here's my big thing.
You can make a million dollars a year,
or a hundred thousand dollars a year,
only talking about ties.
I mean, men's ties.
(laughing)
You have to understand, that's powerful.
Like, what if you grew
up in a fashion family,
you really love ties, maybe your father,
I'm goin' real deep here,
maybe your father died,
and that's like, you know,
but that's where you,
early, when you were a kid, the only thing
you remembered is he wore a great tie.
And then ties became your
thing, and you love ties,
and when you got outta
school you got an internship
at fuckin' who knows, Hugo Boss, and like,
it was all about ties,
the fact that you can now
just post about ties
and write about them on
Instagram, start a podcast
called Ties Tuesdays,
and talk about the
industry, that literally,
if you have persevere, if you're good,
if you find angles, we
now live in a world,
where what I just said, is something that
Hugo Boss, and Fendi and
all these other things,
pay you in sponsorship for your show,
and you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year,
talking about ties, that's wild.
- That's crazy.
It is crazy.
- That's how we started here too,
we broke into tech by doing career change,
and we started sharing on media, right.
- Yeah, we just rolled a story about it
and then people started
asking, how did you do that?
And then we did the podcast
and then we did the video.
- And then you become a media company.
And humans are the media companies now
because the internet is
distribution, and so,
I really want it for people.
Like I want it for people.
Ya know, again, she's sitting here.
Maribel should be writing about things
she's passionate about,
and so should D-Rock,
and so should every single person.
Audio or video.
It's like it's fun, it's interesting,
it leads to opportunities,
you could still have a job.
Ya know, a lotta people risk adverse,
even if it's right in front of their face.
They're makin' one, I got an email,
hey, I'm makin' 130 a year, I'm good,
I finally cleaned up my college debt,
I've got 200 thousand
dollars in sponsorship
around my soccer thing, but
I'm scared to take the leap.
And that's somebody
that's just conservative.
Got taught by parents
like always have a job,
go to school, like, who knows what, right.
Maybe their dad, I mean,
listen, I've seen 'em all now.
Dad took a leap when
they were a kid, failed,
so they had to move out of the house,
now they're scared of entrepreneurship.
Like, I mean, guys, just so you know,
so many people are gonna
lose, over the next 10 years,
that entrepreneurship is not gonna be cool
when I'm in my late fifties and sixties.
Everybody's gonna go the other way.
- Yep.
- Like, that's what happens.
- Cycles.
- And can we talk about college debt?
'cause I think you.
- This is my number one fuckin' passion.
- Please.
- Yeah, and also education 'cause the idea
that you'll go get an
entrepreneurship degree,
and get college debt to
start a business, is.
- An entrepreneur degree,
is the craziest term.
I can't even wrap my head
around what that means.
(laughing)
It makes no fuckin' sense.
That's like, again, that is
getting a baseball degree.
I went to school, and
got a baseball degree.
And now I'm gonna go be a baseball player.
Everybody would laugh you out the window.
- Yep.
- But entrepreneurship, they were able
to finagle, 'cause it wasn't as obvious.
- Yeah.
- That's a really good analogy.
Ya gotta play.
- Gotta fuckin' play.
The fuck do you think entrepreneurship is?
The second you step on the
field, nobody gives a fuck
that your grandfather donated
to the library of that fuckin' school.
- Yep.
Where do you think colleges
are going over the next,
like five, 10 years?
- They'll be the same-ish.
Here's my prediction.
College debt is gonna break our economy.
- Yeah.
- So, here's what I didn't
know, til my friend,
Ryan Serhant, who's on
Million Dollar Listings,
we did this conference
Agent2021 yesterday,
we're havin' breakfast just
to get to know each other
a little bit better, and
he kinda brought it up,
and then I went through this
rabbit hole for the last 48 hours.
I've been shitting on
college debt for a long time,
what I didn't know is how
many people in their twenties,
are getting loans, when
this, any time math
makes no sense, it's over.
Here's the analogy.
You have 213 thousand
dollars in college debt,
on a crazy interest rate.
- Yep.
- You're getting paid 84
thousand dollars a year
in your job, and you were able to borrow
500 thousand dollars to buy an apartment.
- Yep.
- Game over, my friends.
- You can't even pay the principle
'til you're in your thirties.
- Game over.
It's over.
Just so you guys know,
it's over, this economy,
ours, no matter how much
Trump puts in tax reform,
no matter what, this country,
within the next decade,
will coll, the same way the housing crisis
brought down our country,
college, and by the way,
the only reason I'm
saying this, I can't wait
to show this video in
six years and be on CNN
and be like, how'd you know?
(laughing)
I'm not smart, I'm not smart, it's basic.
- Yep.
- It's basic, and you guys know people
that are livin' this right now.
Why does your friend, who
has 413 thousand dollars
in debt, has a bullshit job,
why is he driving a BMW?
- Yeah, that's true.
- Why?
So, shit's gonna hit the fan,
and here's what's gonna happen.
The brand college is gonna
go through the same thing
the brand banks went through.
Everybody's gonna blame college,
we don't blame ourselves.
Your friend, Omar, who has
413 thousand dollars in debt,
who has an 89 thousand dollar a year job,
who decided to borrow 500 thousand dollars
to get that apartment, so
he can take the ladies home,
he's not gonna blame himself.
- Yep.
- He's gonna blame fuckin' Bapson.
And then we're all gonna do that.
- Yep.
- And guess what's gonna happen?
People are gonna stop sending
their fuckin' kids to college.
- Yep.
- And I think nowadays,
especially like our listeners,
they understand there's like
alternatives to college.
- Of course.
- And, a lot of bootcamps,
like Hacker Ac or App Academy,
in three months, you're
able to learn new skill,
and get a job, which, basically
you get paid to learn.
- You mean America in 1930 and 40 and 50?
When vocational skills
mattered, but then college
was built up as a brand, and
it became the American dream.
- Yep.
- Like, people are confused
how this life actually works.
- Yep.
- Like Timur and I are
products of these vocational
schools, we had a
finance degree, whatever,
but how much do we use it today, zero, and
- We're still paying off the loans on it.
- Yeah, we're still paying off the loans
for our finance degree,
by working in software
engineering jobs that we
acquired in less than a year,
so, it's funny how things work out.
- It's interesting.
- Yeah, so we're gonna wrap
up with a lightening round.
- Okay.
- And this is where we ask you questions,
but we're looking for hands on strategies,
tactics, resources that you've used.
- Okay, got it.
- To get you where you are today.
- Black and white, got it.
- Yeah, black and white.
So, this question takes
it back to the basics, and
if you moved to a brand
new city, you only had
$100 and you were starting from scratch,
and you were either starting a business or
breaking into tech, how
would you spend that $100?
- I'd probably spent it
on the subway or the bus,
to get to businesses to walk
directly into the building,
and ask them if I could work
there for a year, for free,
I would serve coffee, I
would do this, and I would
go backwards, I would start with Facebook.
I would start with Facebook or Amazon,
I would move to Seattle or San Francisco,
because I deem them as the best.
Or maybe Netflix, depends
on your interest right?
I'd pick one of the
alpha, alpha companies,
and of course, those three
companies are gonna be like
get the fuck out of here, right?
But you know how life is crazy, right?
Like, I walk into Netflix,
somebody, I'll try
to be loud, I'll try to
make sure there's people
in the audience, and not
loud, like make a scene.
I'd just try to walk in
when there's a lotta people
in the lobby, who are sitting down.
Be like, hey, I'm hungry, I've got skills,
I'm willin' to work for free,
for a year, coffee, whatever.
I think I'm gonna be one
of those weird stories
that he started off as a coffee boy,
and he ended up running the company,
is there anybody, can I talk to HR,
is the boss entrepreneurial like that?
To me, as I'm walking
out, and they're like
get the fuck out of here,
we're gonna call the cops,
I'm wondering, I'll tell you right now,
if I'm sitting in the
lobby, for a big meeting,
at Facebook, and I hear
that, I'll be like hey.
My girl, come over here, what's your name?
Sally.
Send me an email.
'cause that's interesting.
So, I would spend it only on
the cheapest transportation,
to get to the 15 to 30
companies, re-enact that,
over and over, I just know.
- Something's gonna work.
- Yeah.
Because it's me, I'm talented.
- Yep.
- If you're not talented, it won't.
Notice how I didn't say I'm gonna go
do an open workout for the mix.
I keep using sports, I keep using sports,
'cause sports is black and white.
Nobody's ever confused.
- Yeah.
- You could play basketball,
but you can't make a living.
- Yeah.
- Like, you could be an entrepreneur,
but most people are not
gonna make a living.
- What did Ari Gold say?
He said there's no asterisks
in life, only scoreboards.
- It's just true.
Like, I'm just worried.
'cause, I'll tell you what
I'm most worried about.
I do think the kids were overcoddled.
Theoretically, en masse,
in this last generation.
I'm worried about failing.
I'm worried what, it's a public failure.
It's a public failure.
You were the founder, of blue blanket.
It's now out of business.
Nobody's gonna think anything,
there's nowhere to hide.
- Yeah.
- Like, you know, when you made pretend
that you had better grades then you did,
because the system pushed you through,
or your parents did something about it,
or you used money to cover it up,
this one's not gonna work that way.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, we know you talk a lot about
music and things like that.
What is a song, the song
that you play that like
gets you the most motivated when
you wanna just go into work mode.
- Probably Russ', is it me you or you me?
Me you right?
That.
Do you know that song?
- I've never heard it.
- Alright, I'm gonna play it right now,
while you guys think the next thing,
'cause you gotta hear these lyrics,
because you really need to hear it,
it's the, so, there
hasn't been a lotta songs,
historically, that pumped me up,
I'm just pumped up, period.
I don't need fuckin' music, but
this song really, really, really, really,
I really fuck with it, because I
absolutely want good for everybody,
like I'm not kidding, I, it's unbelievable
to me actually, it's weird to me
how much I want all of you to
win, I just wanna beat you.
- Yeah.
- Like I want you to
win, right, but I just
wanna beat you too.
So I have this weird kind of like.
Listen to this.
It gets really, really interesting.
And so, what's interesting about this,
is, this was my life, in a lot of ways,
like, how I lived it, and how I thought
about a lot of my contemporaries,
and how they were living
their lives, right?
So listen.
♪ Me, got it out the
mud, they respect that ♪
♪ Me, always spread the
love when I get back ♪
♪ You, got your hand out,
that's a bitch move ♪
♪ You, always complaining
like a bitch do ♪
♪ Me, still right here
with who I came with ♪
♪ Me, self-made, my
circles on the same shit ♪
♪ You, got a different
crew every weekend ♪
♪ You, don't want it
that bad, keep sleeping ♪
♪ Yeah, you wished for
it, me, I worked for it ♪
♪ Everyone passed on me like Kurt Warner ♪
♪ Search warrant needed,
your career went missin' ♪
♪ This ain't overnight,
this is year ten visions ♪
♪ Peers listen and they
know that I'm up next ♪
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- Like, what he talks about here is like,
when he says this isn't overnight,
this is year 10, I was 34 years old,
when I started VaynerMedia, I had spent
the 12 best years of my youth building
my dad's liquor store for him, I left
that business, had no
money, had no equity,
I was worthless, to the bank.
- And you went in and you sacrificed.
- I gave back, to my family
'cause they gave to me.
- Yep.
- And the end, didn't talk
about it until the last year.
So literally, not only did I do that,
then I went on to become
ridiculously successful,
and watch people write shit
about me that I'm a loser,
and don't listen to him
because his daddy put him on,
when I built my daddy's business for him.
Not only did I do it, which
I don't expect to ever hear
of most people ever doin'
it, I not only did it,
I fuckin' went out and then got shit on,
and then got painted in a
picture, like I got put on,
when I put my dad on
- And touchin' on that, you
also talk about how like
a lot of the things around
you are a distraction, right?
Like, most startups don't die
from homicide, they die from suicide.
- 100%, like, people are
playing the wrong game.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm putting in the
actual work and getting
the actual results, and
even, do you understand
what it is to do something
super noble and kind,
and eat shit for another five years,
where people are saying
those kinda things?
You know how hard, it hurt me.
But, I loved my dad too much
and I didn't even wanna,
like, go there, like, that's just like,
that will always play out.
And that's what I'm tryin' to teach kids,
I'm like don't worry about
what people are saying now.
Like, you literally bought that chain,
to make yourself look good,
to either your homies,
to the girls that you're
chasing, or, to like prove it.
Like this one girl, she's
so awesome, and she's
doing everything just to
stick it to her dad's face,
'cause he didn't believe
in her and I'm like, look,
but now you're doin'
all these stupid things,
'cause you wanna stick it to
your dad's face this year.
I'm like, lemme tell you how it plays out.
You're gonna lose, and
then he's gonna be right.
- Yep.
- Why don't you just eat
more shit and let your dad
shit on you for another
six years, and then
you get to stick it to him forever.
- Yep.
- It's the impatient of sticking it
to somebody that's fuckin' people up.
- Yep.
- I wanna stick it to
everybody, I just knew
that I had to really get
shit on, really get shit on,
guys, I would go see my
friends playing high school,
we would, Thanksgiving,
lotta people go home.
So I would be like 27, right, there's now
five years out of school, and
wine library's on it's path,
for most of you don't know
me, my dad had a business
doin' three million, now it's
like 22, so we've made it,
like I blew it up quick,
we're playing football,
on those Thursdays, you
know, like, on that Friday,
after Thanksgiving,
'cause everybody's back,
your college friends, or your
high school friends, I mean.
So I'm back in the neighborhood,
we're playing football,
some of my friends are
now like on Wall Street,
some of my friends are doin' stuff,
they all pull up in like a
Beamer, this and that, right?
And like, sometimes I'd
see like their siblings,
or like we'd go to like, one
of the houses of the parents,
and literally they would say things like,
this is verbatim, oh, man, so you, so you
work for your dad's liquor store, huh?
(laughing)
- Wow.
- And I'm sittin' there like I'm gonna be
the best entrepreneur of all time.
- Yeah.
- But I'm 27 right now,
and there's 24 year olds
listening right now, that
like wanna make it proof now.
They're just doin' stupid shit.
No patience.
Lack of patience is gonna
kill 90% of the listeners.
- Yeah, and Gary, you talked about.
- I liked how we're gonna
go lightening round,
black and white, and
(laughing)
So, mission accomplished.
- You're doing good, you're
dropping jams, this is great.
So you talk about, kinda your
spirit, your entrepreneurship
spirit, what do you
want your legacy to be?
- That I gave more than I took.
- Oh.
- So I think, I think I get
to be the best entrepreneur
this era, Zucks, and Elon
and Besos, they're gonna
make more money than me, I can feel it,
with every ounce of my soul, right?
I expect to make a ton,
but I'm not catchin' them.
I'm givin' all my content
for free, I'm not doin'
it 'cause I want you to
sign up for my course,
like I'm doin' it, I'm doin' it.
And like, that, I think, makes me,
at least by the way I judge, gives me.
I'll tell you this, more people are comin'
to my funeral than Elon,
Zucks, and Besos combined,
and that makes me feel incredible.
What's gonna happen?
Now look, they're gonna
be like, maybe private,
they might have some private funerals,
I don't know how they're gonna do it.
(laughing)
I think, I think I will touch more people.
And I'm doin' it, because I'm leaving
huge economics on the table.
I'm taking real money out of my pocket,
because you only have 24 hours in a day.
The fuck am I doin' here today?
- Yep.
- Took me the whole day to fly
halfway across the country,
excuse me, across the
country, I mean this, I dunno,
this is one of my days this year.
- We appreciate it.
- Right, and there's 250
days, when you take out,
ya know, like I'm here.
And so like, I'm doin' that for legacy,
I'm doin' that for karma,
I'm doin' it 'cause
it's the right thing to do, and I'm doin'
it by teaching people
how to drink the water.
- Yep.
- Most people that are doin' it, want you
to like, be the horse under them.
- Yep.
- And give you half of their water.
Like you know, you understand,
I'm doin' it so different.
And I'm great at what I do, so it's not,
it's great advice comin' from
somebody who's great at it.
So it's like, you know, it's
literally back to sports.
If you tell me LeBron is fuckin' taking
three hours out of his
day, goin' to fuckin'
high schools and mini
camps and teachin' kids
how to play basketball,
I honestly think that's
what the fuck I'm doing.
That makes me feel real good.
And so, the fact that
I'm gonna get plenty,
I will absolutely have real fuckin' money,
and, the fact that I have real people,
who have really helped it's scale,
that's fucking game changing, crushin' it.
I love when people, I
post about crushin' it,
they're like oh, Gary V.,
see, he acts like he cares,
he wants you to buy the
book, I'm like motherfucker,
it's 17 dollars.
If you think my book is
a good use of my time,
you're outta your fuckin' mind.
I wrote the book, 'cause
a lotta people don't learn
from one minutes videos
on Instagram, or one
Medium post, a lotta
people learn from books.
- Yep.
- I write books 'cause
people learn from them.
I don't.
But like, my fuckin' book deal's bullshit.
- Everybody learns differently, so I mean,
I think on that note man, I think it's,
we look forward to reading your book,
we look forward to seeing you being
the future owner of the New York Jets.
- Thank you.
- We'll check out the shoes
and everything like that,
and is there a way so
everybody can keep in touch?
- You three have to, forget about keepin',
yeah it's GaryVee, you'll
find me, but you three
need to make the commitment,
I got a real fresh sneaker
comin' out, June.
- Hell yeah.
- Yeah, that's good, we'll do it.
- The last one sold out crazy.
- Of course.
- But, this time we're
making a fuckload, so.
- Hell yeah.
- We're in there.
- Now I need everybody to buy 'em.
- We'll get those, for sure.
- We're on board.
For Breaking Starups community.
- Sold some sneakers on
the way out, see you.
- Thank you, peace.
- Peace out.
- All right, peace out, thanks.
- [Man] Can we get a group picture with--
- Yeah.
- Thank you man.
- You're welcome man, that was fun.
- Let's do the whole crew, c'mon.
- You got that radio, silky voice.
- All right dude, trying to man.
- Yeah, Gary.
(mellow music)